thank you
[Music]
welcome back to another careful voice we
are very careful boys and today we are
talking indeed about some adult topics
that people want to hear about because
Market macros we're talking about
the housing market
yay let's talk about something we can't
afford this guy's gonna come right now
take it away what do you mean what the
[__]
housing talk about looking at him house
[__] what have you been learning no
honestly so so we're in 20 20 [__]
three barely how do you feel about the
housing market how do you feel about the
economy macros wise how do you feel
about uh the environment the landscape
the environment the landscape and trying
to make it not boring yeah
um so I guess a lot of people that are
watching are in the age of either
wanting to buy a house or considering it
let's see we're gonna wake up ordinary
dead from old age yeah or minimum wage
in the near future and so I think for a
lot of people with the interest rates
going up they're like how the [__] am I
ever gonna afford this [__] exactly you
see all these Instagram comparisons
right they're like right now I think
pretty much the cost of a 400 000 house
the mortgage payment is the same as a
house that's like seven or eight hundred
thousand just based off interest rate
yeah so they're like it's like plus six
percent yeah so they're like oh that's
awesome them that the [__] demand is
way lower but the affordability isn't
higher you know just because there's
less people in the market but the
interest rate's so high the mortgage is
still [__] it's still really really
high
so for a lot of investors I think for
them it's like okay this is kind of cool
you're kind of shaking out the market
and shaking out the people that aren't
really really interested and then see if
we can come in and just scoop like a
mofo are they shaking them like on both
sides of their face and their tits yeah
they're like shaking like this and like
this
but what are all the employees that just
lost their jobs that at Twitter gonna do
they can't buy a house I feel like those
guys anyone that's in Silicon Valley
like if you know if anyone's like job
packages they're pretty set okay
from what's a mortgage because I follow
them online he has been talking about
how unemployment rates in America have
not been going up they've actually been
slightly declining according to the last
report yeah so he encourages people to
still buy if you're in that place that
to want to close but then feel free to
refinance later when the rates do drop
back and to all the stupid [__] out
there
I need to go find myself
when they look at your [__] finances
and [__] they're like okay cool let me
see your last three years W-2 if you
don't hold the job there goes your
[__] chances of owning a house you
[__] stupid find yourself [__] what
if you found a wealth of personal
discovery
but can you quantify that well that's
awesome well guess what you're never
gonna have a home you gotta get another
job and have to hold it for like two or
three I think that's cool I got a tent
on Venice Beach and I live just as good
as the millionaire neighbors around me
then that's good for them that's good
news yeah I got a Coleman tent it's
pretty sick and then like I just pitch
it in front of the beach in a
four-person town I have a really good
view is it knife proof because that
might be a problem I mean
oh [__] damn you Coleman the suckers
around me they gotta pay millions but I
get it for free so suckers but a lot of
people are just waiting homeowners hate
this guy they're waiting for the
interest rates to drop back down I think
the 2024 or whatever what's more
affordable but the problem is it's
always like it's like that right with
the interest rates dropped the man goes
up again everyone floods the market so
now the cost of homes go back up it goes
back up again so that's the tough part
where you're trying to balance supply
and demand but you're also really trying
to balance affordability I think that's
the main issue that people aren't really
addressing is just because the interest
rates go down and then like it doesn't
mean it's more affordable
so that's the part of that kind of sucks
I think it is like the American dream
like everyone has this like Oh I wanna
after college I want to get married I
want to have a house but especially in
like the bigger cities New York San
Francisco L.A it's [__] almost
impossible dude you know so last year we
were just talking about this the average
house price in
um [__] La was like 700 or something
thousand now it's 800 something that's
the average you know the [__]
Monterey Park house I had like our first
home I looked it up just for shits and
giggles that [__] 950 now whoa
and what is your volume just like a
regular ass [__] what'd you sell it
for um I bought it for like low seven I
think I got it for like 7 30.
[__] you suck yeah because you could
have made way more
we just realized we outgrew it was too
small it was like perfect for me and Geo
and then the minute we had a kid and
then family started coming in we're like
oh [__] like like uh was like 1500
square feet or whatever like that does
not cut it once family starts coming
over you may you may weigh more in that
Vegas house though oh yeah a little bit
more on that one yeah my [__] lost value
like my [__] why it pumped up like a
[__] I was like whoa 40 000 in
like two months and then it just crashed
like nothing and all I lost 15K did our
[__] what up like 120 000. it was crazy
but then yeah it went right back down do
you know what caused that this is the
time yeah it's just but then I mean I
mean it's gonna over time it's gonna go
up on pre-interest rates right people
were trying to lock in like better
mortgage rates so then like it's like oh
I can get it for two percent two point
five percent two point seven five
percent awesome but then now it's like
five percent so people like I'm more
scared so the thing is now the house is
the absolute price is more affordable
so if you can qualify for a loan the
cool thing is you're not going to be
competing with people whereas before it
was like all cash offers 50k 100K over
asking waive all contingencies I'm not
even going to expect those I don't give
a [__] if your pipes are burst I'm
coming up for new yeah yeah for sure
like that they'll do all kinds of like
technically irresponsible [__] I just
want the house I'm not even gonna like
check to see if things are good if it
has termites or whatever but now if you
can't afford it's actually a good time
to buy in my opinion because you can buy
it interest rates fluctuate but then if
you hold on to the absolute price in
2024 when the interest rates drop you
can refund yeah and then your mortgage
rate will get dropped by a [__] ton
that's the game but I don't know because
we're all in like positions where we
actually were able to even buy a house
and like
a lot of people can't like this this is
just impossible it's insane especially
if you're in L.A five percent it's
sometimes six if your credit ain't great
or more but I think the hard truth is
though I think
people can they just don't want to move
that's I think the hard truth yeah where
people they want their cake and eat it
too and it's like oh but I I grew up in
New York I want to buy in New York and
it's like well [__] you better make like
half a million dollars a year yeah right
but we are seeing an exodus though from
all the California New York Hawaii like
major I think it was like 15 000 people
left Hawaii like hundreds of thousands
left
um [__] California New York and then
they went to more affordable States so
those were the people that were able to
be like you know what I work remote or
like I could find a job elsewhere like
us we went to Vegas right but then like
what about people who are working class
or whatever and they're just their roots
are all in California or like they just
all their family and friends that's I
think that's the difficult part where
like it is the family and friends is the
heart they're talking to us you guys
we're talking to us you know luckily all
of us were able to buy houses [__]
morons and you know we don't got no
roots here the families and friends over
like generationally like they've been
around like even Jill's parents and [__]
or like just the community that they're
in and they can't fathom leaving but
they're dumb because I'm like just
[__] a few
your ass was living in Mexico
you were uprooting that's true nobody
really got roots in California that
means it means you had new Roots I know
California is a new ass State [__] yeah
I'm like don't flip-flop like you've
been here for [__] 10 Generations
that's right because all the different
neighborhoods that we have here they're
like less than 50 years old exactly yeah
most most of the Japanese people have
been here longer I know yeah yeah that's
the funny part really dude yeah the
[__] rush hour Chinese restaurant I
mean they're way longer than that yeah
that's true I do think though the
hardest thing about like moving is the
community and upbringing like uh just
leaving your life like I think that's
why it's just like it's affordable but
[__] also leaving your source of income
yeah that's a big one through making
Nikki's parents come to us for
Thanksgiving was [__] die they came
to Vegas yeah and for Thanksgiving I
[__] did a turkey and everything was
that their first time at your guys's
house
and we brought it yeah I think he was a
hater doubter why yo she was saying I
wouldn't do the turkey oh she was saying
like oh I wouldn't get it done in time
and guess what I [__] did it yeah and
well you actually made a turkey I made a
turkey and you didn't burn it or nothing
did all of it it was juicy it was good
you did it from scratcher did you get it
from the market and you warmed it up in
the oven I got it from trash
Oh yeah I I no I bought I made it from
scratch from Boston Market I bought like
a I bought like a frozen turkey days in
advance
store yeah I thought it out and
everything and Nikki never thought I
could [__] do it damn dude he showed
her I love it I love putting that [__]
wrong I love it you're very domestic huh
a little bit what else do you do that's
very good was her dad like how much did
you pay for this house and he's like
what the [__] yeah no he's been awesome
he's her dad's my dude he's the best
dude he's honestly the best he's known
how what a good deal it was there oh
yeah oh he's just impressed because like
it's like a 3 000 square foot home and
he's like holy [__] and like his house
looks like a [__] toilet
what kind of toilet though yeah yeah
like the ones we have here we got some
fancy toilets public restroom at a beach
and you know a beach and you know had a
KOA Campground yeah that was the worst
dude no he's the best he's so he's so
awesome he's the white one yeah uh no
he's the white one oh he's a Filipino
one I always forget which one's which
her mom is is full away yeah cool but no
that's like it was a gangster he's the
man but no he's um yeah it was it's just
been really cool and um we love our
place but then getting to host was like
oh it's kind of Addicting so now I'm
like okay you want to throw more events
play for Christmas next year that's cool
you have a very classic host house like
you got like two living rooms thank you
how would you know huh have you been to
my house no we're not friends
so but you know decorating for Christmas
too was important because like my nieces
and nephews were coming so I was like I
wanted them to like remember you're kind
of like that like I wanted them to
remember memories Christmas lights
stupid [__] led reindeer in the lawn
don't forget those ones either exactly
yeah those are the magical ones yeah and
my uh my nephew at the time got sick and
then they had to like leave early and my
niece and nephew crying on the way home
which is good for me
because they wanted to stay and they
wanted to come back
a little shot across the bow at my
family being [__] degenerates
because they can't stop being Hoarders
my sister is a hoarder like my mother
right it's like [__] a disease
and my um nephews my nephew and niece
were like man like Uncle Stephen and
Nikki their house is so clean like it'd
be so cool for houses like this it'd be
cool if you could see our driveway oh no
and then my sister's like okay well you
know how to do that right you have to
get rid of your toys and I'm like this
is why it's a disease Jesus [__]
Christ blame it on someone else
ouch they won't even know the toys are
gone are they the kind that like they
don't park the car in the garage because
there's nowhere to put it yeah they just
park it on the lawn because the driveway
is full of like old boats and trailers
and stuff garbage garbage unidentifiable
things that look like AI best example
best example this actually happened my
niece hands my brother-in-law a block of
wood that she marked up with a marker
and it's like she Drew like Santa Claus
looks like [__] I
and then
it looks like [__] and then and then
it's not gonna remember this yeah my
sister hands it to my brother-in-law and
she's like hey hey Jeff can you go like
you know put this in the garage because
like this is awesome and I just put it
in the [__] garbage I'm like Jeff be
a man putting a [__] burn in Jeff he
did that he didn't have you think it's
because she's gonna remember she goes
she's in the garage she's like wait
where's that where's Clara's [__]
wood block Claire did a wood Buck
where's the wood block with the [__]
shitty Sandy on it and you will you
won't hear the end of it I'm telling you
bro and yeah he knows because he's there
when I'm not there like I'm not their
Defender so he's like I'm gonna go down
he's like Steve won't be here to defend
me I'm going to go down [__] I get what
he did because he's like he's like I
wanna I really do but then he put it
away in storage and I was like you
little [__] you little man you're a
tiny little man oh man you guys did have
a very like hosty house yeah it's nice
yeah it's like coming kick it yeah thank
you this is great I feel like Vegas
though has a lot of space to create like
a more middle class
family environment which is so ironic
because of itself ideal but it's so
[__] like kind of Steph Steph were
wifey it's like middle class 50s era
golden like I love it what but it's thin
City yeah but the cool thing is if you
just don't go to actual strip it's like
it's not there no it's like nice
Riverside uh why would you go to Vegas
then
I probably spent about
um once a week going on to this trip
like whatever at least one really yeah
because I love people watching and I
thought living in Vegas would ruin the
Vegas for me and you're wrong but what
ended up happening was I had so much
more time to explore the other parts of
Vegas that I didn't get to because every
single time because it was a vacation
what ended up happening was I'm just
doing my favorites and then I go home
and I was like you know what I'll go to
Pawn Stars but I ain't here for that
[__] that I'm here to do the things that
I like to do like I got a gamble I Gotta
Eat Here and then you're done right but
then now I get to do the Pawn Stars the
[__] big pinball thing I could do all
these other side side missions I'm
getting off a plane no joke no [__]
I'm getting off a plane I'm coming back
from JK this is like uh two months ago I
get off the plane there's Rick from Pawn
Stars Boom right here it's close to me
as you he was on the same fly as me and
him and not chunley the other kid
he was on his his son yeah they were
both on the fight with me oh cool say
what up I'm with the Pawn Stars but it's
one of those things like I get now
because like it happens to us in in
public right because we're so [__]
famous that like people like holy [__] I
can't believe it's you and you don't
want to do it to them yeah yeah yeah but
no but it's one of those things where
like you look at them for a second and
then you're like
[Applause]
there's a few seconds where you think
it's someone that you like you know each
other and you go oh I know that's one
way we're friends oh no that's a one-way
Road you guys watched you review a civil
war guys
I just tell them I'm a big fan like I
saw Michael Bisping oh sick when I uh
got to the airport
oh [__] that's [__] Michael Bisping
and then I could tell like he was just
trying to get a sandwich but all the
stores were closing so we just go from
one store to the other and I was like uh
I was like I could sell he's not in a
good mood okay Michael was a big fan
that's it you know I mean I give him a
catch some like Bob Knuckles and then I
just walked away because I I um I went
to a Premiere in La of heat you guys
know I love heat my favorite movies ever
and I and Michael Mann was there and
like afterward I I was like Michael man
I'm a hugest fan ever I [__] love you
and I I don't want a picture I just like
I just wanted to shake his hand that's
what I did that's right he's like thank
you thank you that's almost better than
getting a picture yeah yeah I just don't
want to bug him too much but I bugged
him anyway and then he pushed me he's
like what he's I was like I don't want
to bug you he's like like you're doing
right now
[Laughter]
that's the funniest thing when a fan was
like Hey I don't I don't mean to erupt
interrupt anything and they're literally
like interrupting yeah it's the funniest
thing ever I don't mean to interrupt at
all
I literally am with my body can I take a
picture yeah and then the mini go yeah
when we were at Boston Market in the
valley Justin Bieber was sitting there
was just him and his like what One
Security whatever Victor Victor goes
right up to like like goes down in the
table hey Justin can't get a photo and
Justin goes I'm eating
and the victors all okay
I was like yeah dude easy
like wait a little more dick huh yeah I
can't believe you did that douchebag huh
but we were all like Victor you're an
idiot
clearly he's like literally like about
that yeah yeah he was about to start
eating let the plane get to the [__]
tarmac first get to the destination
Justin Bieber's going in for surgery
he's like hey can I get pictures
laughs Anthony have you met anybody
famous before me dude he's met like
Jackie Chan all sorts of like not on a
gig that's the
that's
randomly not not like that but like a
greatest highlight of my life ran into
cold had to say hi I'm Anthony leader of
the kinjas Jay King the leader of the
kids now um what I did do was I I was uh
I saw John Bernthal at uh Universal
Studios whoa yeah and I think he's dope
and the touch on beach full name yeah I
I wanted to like say what's up and or
get a photo but then uh he kept on kind
of like walking this way walking this
way and I don't want to stop forever and
then by the time I was like all right
cool he's posting up and I started going
over but then like a bunch of like his
either his kids or like other kids like
Family Camp and I was like that's what
you hit him with I don't want to
interrupt but I was like three minutes
into the journey too you know when
you're into the chase you're kind of
winning you're trying to be respectful
and you're just kind of like going but
it didn't work I met Mark rafala oh
really yeah
raffle tickets host Hulk too not like
rom-com Mark raffle oh I meant Not Just
Like Heaven just like if that movie
and there was a guy guy with him who's
like you could tell that he was bugging
more grapple he was like he's like his
lawyer or some [__] but like he's going
around telling everybody like I got Mark
Ruffalo he's with me and [__] he's
amazed my boy and we're boys we boys
together and then you can tell Marcus
just like God [__] damn it why I
agree to this [__] should stay in my
room but like he's like walk and mock
raffle around like he has a petting zoo
I'm like poor Mark had to take pictures
with [__] like me yeah it was great
it was really fun dude can I tell you
real quick of mystery that I solved that
like I res like one time I said it here
and I didn't know the answer and now I
do so like I I had said before that
every time I sign up for a new app or
something like a major app like Tick
Tock or some kind of mail thing it'll go
oh would you like to add these people
from your contacts
and it would always come up Meghan
Trainor is in my contacts no way I go
how the [__] how do I I don't know
Meghan Trainor yeah why is she it would
always go oh you can add these people
they're in your phone book I'm like
which one but you don't know which one
or number is because like I go through
it I'm like I don't have her saved so if
I ran a train on it Megan
I think that's what it is and it was
just a big pun
so like I would try to figure that out
I don't think that's what it is and then
I thought back I'm like oh there was one
time that I do remember Meghan Trainor
went up to Redfoo when we were a club
and she was like Hey like we should do
music time and he was like yeah yeah and
then she walked away and then he goes
who's that and I was like that's closer
ever came I didn't take her number down
or anything so I'm like there's no way I
have her in my phone turns out I go to a
baby shower one of my friends and then
um one of her friends who I used to be
on tour with when she was doing media
she goes hey I'm making Trader's manager
now
and I went that's how cause her number
she manages Meghan Trainor's accounts so
it's her number that's on all of Meghan
Trainor's personal [__] oh that's so
[__] random isn't that dope well
that's it it's not her it's it's your
management it's your Management's
personal number so you didn't run a
train on Omega yeah what'd you bring
that one up for yeah why'd you say that
it's for a later episode
when we're off for the record
thank you